y
[Música]
continúa la crisis por el despliegue
militar en la frontera de entre rusia y
ucrania estados unidos y europa preparan
una respuesta en caso de que la
diplomacia falle la casablanca la otan y
también rusia ya preparan a miles de
soldados
790 personas enfrentan procesos
judiciales en cuba por haber participado
en las protestas antigubernamentales de
julio de 2021 la fiscalía emitió un
informe en el que agrega que al menos 55
adolescentes están siendo investigados
la delegación enviada por la comisión
internacional de derechos humanos a
chile para investigar la reacción
gubernamental tras el estallido social
de 2019 ratificó el uso desproporcionado
de la fuerza y la criminalización de la
protesta ampliamos desde santiago
buenas tardes y bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 yo soy maría clara
calle y comenzamos hablando de eeuu y
europa que están coordinando una
respuesta conjunta frente al despliegue
militar ruso en la frontera con ucrania
el presidente joe biden reiteró hoy que
enviará tropas en coordinación con los
socios europeos y la otan por su parte
del presidente francés emmanuel mayo se
reunió con el canciller alemán olaf
scholz ambos reiteraron su esfuerzo
coordinado para responder en caso tal de
que la diplomacia fallen akrón hablará
además el viernes con su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin para pedirle claridad
sobre cuál es su postura frente a kiev
fassett situación no son estamos
completamente unidos y coordinados ante
esta situación como estados miembros de
la unión europea como países aliados
dentro de la organización de tratado del
atlántico norte
lo segundo es nuestra solidaridad con
ucrania alemania y francia- se
solidarizan muy claramente y la comisión
europea ha anunciado en los últimos días
nuevos compromisos en lo que respecta a
ucrania también estamos todos atentos
para proteger a ucrania en el pleno
cibernético ya que ha sufrido varios
ataques en las últimas semanas así pues
en este contexto nos solidarizamos con
ucrania y nos comprometemos plenamente
mientras sigue insistiendo en la
diplomacia occidente se prepara para una
respuesta militar y ya comenzó a mandar
equipamiento a ucrania la situación es
tal que canadá retirará temporalmente a
los hijos menores de 18 años y a los
familiares de sus diplomáticos en kiev
así ha aumentado el despliegue militar
en la frontera ruso-ucraniana
unidad total sobre ucrania después de
una llamada de 80 minutos con los
líderes europeos la otan joe biden dijo
a los periodistas que la alianza
occidental está unida he tenido una muy
muy muy buena conversación unanimidad
total con todos los líderes europeos en
medio de los temores de un plan de rusia
para invadir ucrania el presidente de
eeuu ha puesto a unos 8.500 soldados
estadounidenses en alerta en caso de
necesidad podrían desplegarse para
ayudar a la cerca de cuatro mil tropas
de la otan en los países bálticos y a
las cinco mil tropas estadounidenses y
de la otan que ya están en polonia
estamos estudiando la posibilidad de
reforzar aún más nuestra presencia en la
parte oriental de la alianza lo que
podría incluir el despliegue de grupos
de combate adicionales de la otan más de
100.000 soldados rusos y adrián ucrania
por el norte el este y el sur pero rusia
niega estar planeando una invasión con
las tensiones elevadas los estados
miembros de la otan están realizando
maniobras de precaución dinamarca en una
fragata y desplegó cuatro aviones de
caza a lituania españa ofreció en el
heads a bulgaria y barcos al mar negro
los países bajos enviarán dos aviones de
guerra a bulgaria mientras que estonia
letonia y lituania enviaron misiles
antitanques y antiaéreos a ucrania y
francia enviaría tropas a rumanía el
portavoz de vladimir putin declaró a los
medios rusos que la otan y eeuu eran los
culpables de la escalada de tensiones
está generosamente aderezada con una
gran cantidad de información falsa el
gobierno francés anunció que
funcionarios rusos ucranianos franceses
y alemanes se reunirán en parís el
miércoles para intentar sacar
diplomáticamente a europa del este del
abismo
rusia cataloga al opositor alexéi
navalni como terrorista y extremista el
servicio federal de supervisión
financiera ruso lo agrego a esa lista
junto a dos de sus mayores aliados
políticos eso implica que las cuentas
bancarias de dichos opositores rusos
estarán congeladas y necesitan una
aprobación cada vez que las quieran usar
mientras tanto navalny sigue en prisión
desde hace luego de haber sido
envenenado en rusia
en cuba acusan a 790 personas por
participar en las protestas
antigubernamentales del 11 de julio del
2021 así lo anunció la fiscalía general
en un informe en el que también explica
que entre los investigados hay 55
adolescentes que tienen entre 16 y 18
años 28 de ellos están en prisión
provisional todos los acusados son
señalados de actos vandálicos y graves
alteraciones del orden mientras las ongs
denuncian una persecución y juicios sin
el debido proceso vamos a ver hasta
ahora a santa clara cuba donde está 6
lee gonzález ella es parte del equipo
promotor de la marcha de archipiélago
señora gonzález bienvenida a france 24
se puede entender estos procesos como
una persecución a quienes se oponen al
gobierno de miguel díaz canel
por supuesto que sí muchísimas gracias
por también por acá y repito por
supuesto que si se puede entender
exactamente de esa manera además vimos
en este artículo que saca un medio
oficial el primero acá en cuba un
marcado sesgo político donde intentan
justificar todo esto alegando que estas
personas eran delincuentes diciendo que
tenían antecedentes penales como por
ciento bastante alto de esas personas y
con esto quieren quitarle el carácter
político pero luego habla de que se
están juzgando por delitos de sedición
un delito que es eminentemente político
y las organizaciones han dicho que no
son 790 procesados sino que hay más de
1.000 detenidos finalmente cuál podría
ser la cifra y en qué condiciones está
estas personas
si las organizaciones de derechos
humanos han llevado un conteo por
ejemplo que ya no es defender aula en su
último informe de 955 y la fiscalía
general de la república a través del
artículo de cubadebate habla de estos
790 personas nada más el tema es que si
son artistas de justicia 11-j cuales las
organizaciones de derechos humanos a que
en cuba también el observatorio cubano
de derechos humanos contabilizan además
las personas que fueron detenidas o sea
que han sido detenidas luego del 11 de
julio contabilizan además las personas
que fueron detenidas por el 15 de
noviembre que también hubo detenidas las
personas que han sido detenidas a lo
largo del año por manifestarse en contra
el sistema entre por ejemplo luís manuel
otero alcántara y artista hoy en huelga
de hambre sexto día huelga de hambre y
sed del cual además la sociedad civil
cual está viviendo un momento de vida
hay también cuatro personas más en
huelga de hambre acá en cuba de l'esprit
y según las leyes cubanas que puede
pasar con los menores de edad que están
siendo procesados podrían ir a la cárcel
o no muy brevemente
y por supuesto pueden ir a la cárcel
porque además en las leyes cubanas
entienden a las personas que entienden
la mayoría de edad y que se pueden hacer
juicios con él después de los 16 años
por lo tanto aunque son menores de edad
no las entienden cómo está que puedan
procesarlos perfectamente perfecto
señoras y gonzález gracias por estar con
nosotros en otras noticias la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
publicó un informe sobre qué ocurrió en
las protestas de chile en 2019 el
reporte ratifica que hubo un uso
excesivo de la fuerza pública y eso
afectó el derecho a la protesta pacífica
también evidenció hostigamientos por
parte de agentes del estado a diversos
sectores de la sociedad incluidos la
prensa desde santiago el periodista de
france 24 leonardo honores tiene los
detalles
hace dos años una delegación de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos él visitó chile para conocer en
terreno cuál es la situación de los
derechos humanos específicamente en el
país luego del estallido social sus
conclusiones recogidas en 125 páginas
son lapidarias se da cuenta de que o
vulneraciones a los derechos
fundamentales así como también un uso
desmedido de la fuerza de parte de los
agentes policiales otro de los aspectos
importantes de esta concluyente informe
es que de parte del ejecutivo
hubo una mirada que puso en duda
justamente la legitimidad de las
manifestaciones al criminalizar las
específicamente hay que recordar que uno
de los momentos más complejos de todo
este proceso fue cuando el presidente
viniera señaló que se estaba en guerra y
encontró un enemigo poderoso haciendo
alusión justamente a quienes estaban en
las calles protestando por distintas
causas sociales dentro de estas
conclusiones de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos se
ponen especial énfasis en la reparación
en particular para las personas que
sufrieron traumas oculares o daños
permanentes productos de los agentes
represivos en este caso la policía
hay un elemento adicional se hace un
foco en particular respecto de la escasa
preparación del cuerpo policial de
carabineros en chile- que debido a la
alta demanda que se debieron ha obligado
justamente a enfrentar producto de
múltiples manifestaciones no dieron
abasto cometiendo excesos que en algunos
casos parecían ser sistemáticos de allí
importancia que la convención
interamericana de derechos humanos pone
uno de los énfasis particulares la
reparación específica para todos quienes
fueron vulnerados durante este periodo y
con esta noticia de chile terminamos
nuestra emisión informativa pero los
invitamos a que sigan conectados a la
programación de france 24
[Música]